اذا تغطيتنا مستمره للتطورات التي يشهدها
قطاع غزه وخلال الدقائق الماضيه وكما
تابعنا فقد افاد مصدر في حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي للجزيره باستشهاد شخصين احدهما
مسؤول بارز في سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري
للحركه كما اصيب اخرون نتيجه قصف اسرائيلي
استهدف شقه سكنيه في حي النصر شمال غربي
مدينه غزه وقد اندلعت النيران في الشقه
السكنيه المستهدفه كما لحقت اضرار ماديه
كبيره في المنازل المجاوره للمكان
المستهدف ونقلت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه عن
مسؤول امنيا ان المستهدفه في حي النصر هو
المسؤول عن العمليات في حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي
اغتياله مسؤول العمليات في حركه الجهاد
الاسلاميه كانت تطور الابرز ضمن سلسله
التطورات التي شهدها قطاع غزه خلال
الساعات الاخيره حيث قصفت طائرات الاحتلال
عده مواقع في قطاع غزه وقال الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه قصف ايضا اربعه مواقع
عسكريه تابعه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي في
غزه احدها تابع لقائد كتيبه رفح في الحركه
واشار الى ان القصف شمل موقعين تابعين
للجهاد الاسلامي يستخدمان للتخطيط واداره
اطلاق الصواريخ في غزه بدورها جددت
المقاومه الفلسطينيه اطلاق دفعات صاروخيه
صوب اسرائيل ودوات صفارات الانذار في تجمع
مستوطنات غوش عطسيون قربه بيت لحم كما
احدث قصف من غزه اصابه مباشره في مبنى
سكني في مدينه سبيروت وفي مبنى ببلده كفر
عزه جنوب غلاف غزه بينما طالت الصواريخ
ضواحي مدينه القدس وهو ما وصفته حركه
الجهاد بانه رساله لان ما يجري هناك ليس
بمعزل عن القطاع هذا وقالت لاذاعه
الاسرائيليه الرسميه ان اسرائيل ابلغت
مصرى بوقف محادثات وقف اطلاق النار بينما
مددت السلطات الاسرائيليه حاله الطوارئ
الى مساء غد السبت